Anat Peled, thank you so much for joining
me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks for having me.
It's great to be here.
You're actually calling
from Stanford Campus,
you're at the Hillel Building. Right?
I am. I am. There's lots of pulley books
behind me so.
Wonderful. And actually, so the reason
that you're still in campus is because
you're finishing your senior year.
You recently finish your Senior Thesis.
Your honor's thesis.
You actually won an award.
What was it? The Kennedy Award?
It's an award for the best Jewish studies.
Like the best thesis on the Jewish topic.
It's called the Donald and Robin Kennedy
Undergraduate Award, so.
Insane. So, we're gonna have to talk
a little bit about what that is.
But your journey is so fascinating.
And really the reason why I think
this is gonna be such a fun conversation
is because you and I come from
very similar backgrounds.
From Israel.
Very Israeli we've made a transition
to Stanford.
For me it was a dream.
My whole life, I didn't know what to expect.
And I think, it's such a unique transition.
While I'm in technology, you're actually
more on the humanities.
And you're specifically passionate
about history.
You're a Rhode Scholar.
And you're going to study in Oxford
next year. Right?
Yeah. I am.
Unbelievable.
Hopefully it's okay with a, you know.
It will be on Zoom but,
Okay. So Anat, just how many people
get the Rhodes scholar a year?
Well, Israel it's very new.
So, only two people get it from Israel.
But yeah, it's very competitive.
Very very right.
So, whoever doesn’t know, I mean
Rhodes scholar, whoever hears that name
It is an academia.
It's like one of the biggest things
you can accomplish.
One of the biggest scholarships
you can get.
So Anat, just tell me a little bit about
yourself? Where do you come from?
And why are you at Stanford?
What are you finishing in Stanford now?
Totally. Yeah. So, I'm from Israel.
I'm from Ra'anana.
Yeah. I mean, yes, I grow up
speaking Heblish, so Hebrew and English.
So, I'm kinda in both of those worlds.
Did high school in Israel.
Then went to the army.
And I've served in Intelligence.
in one of my time.
And then I worked a little bit
in a non-profit where
we brought together Muslims and Jews.
together through martial arts.
So that was a lot of fun.
Do you know martial arts yourself?
I don't. I was the only one.
I was the Project Manager.
Of course. Of course.
I was the only one there
who was not a black belt.
Yeah, and after that I applied to Stanford.
It was a dream of mine to get this
Liberal Arts Education.
Which is very different than in Israel.
Where you know, you apply years.
You know, you study this.
And you don’t really get a lot of
kind of exploring outside.
And so I came to Stanford.
Fell in love with history.
Yeah, and next year,
So, Anat before we jump to history.
Because you know, a lot of my friends
and colleagues from 8200
and from generally Tel Aviv in Israel,
They're watching this and while
You and I had a very
interesting experience in Stanford.
I think that it's very different from
the ordinary university approach
that Israel has.
I don’t know if it's better or worse.
But it's different. And I'd love for you
to give me, you know, your true sense
of what was the Stanford experience
from you having gone through
four years of it now?
Yeah. So, first of all if any Israelis
who are watching this and
thinking about coming.
Totally apply.
It's really great. And it's possible.
If we did it, it's possible.
It is possible.
If they were willing to take me on
Anybody can get it, I'm telling you.
Yeah. So, it's just been amazing.
Because you get the opportunities here
are really,
You think of it, you can make it happen.
They have the funds.
They have the best professors here.
And as for me, I kind of studied history.
I love it. But it also, I study it
'cause it didn't get in the way
of my education.
I could take the best classes,
the best teachers from other department.
Yeah, I've done a lot of political science.
And journalism. And anthropology.
Like all kinds of stuff.
Was there a specific class or moment
that really, you know, that's a key
or a Stanford highlight?
Or is it a combination of bunch of things?
I will tell you about a crazy class
that I took. It's such a Stanford thing.
So, basically, it was two weeks
intensive seminar called,
The Face of Battle.
It was for people who finish their first year
going to their second year.
And I get this okay.
So, it was about war.
And so we studied two battles.
We got assigned a character
from each side of the battles.
So, we studied Gettysburg.
And we get assigned a confederate
in the union. And on another battle
a little big horn, so.
So, the American civil war, right?
Yeah. The first battles the Civil war?
The second one was a little bit later.
But, and then basically you plan a speech.
As the character.
Then you fly to the battlefield.
They flew us to you know,
to DC in Montana, and you give speeches
as the characters.
Where the battle happened.
So, I give a speech as Robert E. Lee
the Confederate General in Gettysburg.
Yeah, it was pretty wild.
Like John Huston. Yeah.
Wow. Okay. So, really summing it up.
The idea also what I feel similar to you,
I mean, the opportunities are endless.
And you get to really explore whatever
your passion is.
And while Stanford is really well known
for its computer science and mathematics
Here you are doing history, and saying,
"Yeah, I had won one of the most
incredible experiences I could have hope
for in history."
And what was your honors thesis
is about?
Yeah. So, my honors thesis is about
actually, Israel. It's about the Kibbutz.
I studied about you know,
I look into the period of the 1920s.
The first Kibbutz was found, okay,
So, for people who don't know
what the Kibbutz is?
Yes.
It's a one of a kind wacky idea
Basically, people say it's the
most successful form of
democratics socialism ever.
Ever. Like ever. It still exists today.
Not exactly the same form.
But basically all property was shared.
And it was all decisions were made
through communal meeting
It was an agricultural settlement.
Yeah. And so, I looked at the 1920s
when, the first Kibbutz was found in 1910.
The kids started to be born in 1920s.
And I wanted to see what this kind of
fanatical socialist who came from
the struggle in Europe.
You know from this background of
Jewish kind of you know,
you're gonna grow up to be a rabbi,
the girls are mother.
It suddenly came and they were socialist.
And you know, with socialism
there's this idea that the
Bourgeois family, you know
the mom, the husband, the children,
its property. That’s bourgeois.
We're trying to get rid of it.
So, what do these people do?
And I studied the family in the Kibbutz.
And I try to see how they reimagined it.
Suddenly the kids where
everyone’s children.
They raised kids in communal homes.
But it was very painful process.
So I looked at a lot of meeting minutes.
Alef [--]
Who is a philosopher.
Who actually did a lot on the family.
So, it a was a lot of fun for me
to rediscover the history
of my own country, and--
Did you read a lot of this in Hebrew?
The primary sources?
Its all in Hebrew. Yeah, I did some
archival research in Israel.
at Degania Alef. That would be so cool.
Yeah.
Wow. Okay. But Anat, one of things
that you mention to me right before
right before we start.
And I think it ties very nicely to
to this research that you did.
You said one of the reasons you think
you got the Rhodes scholarship
is because you told them,
"Listen. I want to be a top bidder."
That is sort of a life goal of yours.
What does that mean to you?
Because when I started this show,
I said, my pitch was,
"I wanna interview proud leaders
from around the world."
So, I very much resonate with this
ambition to be a tough leader.
That was I aspire myself.
What does it mean for you?
Yeah. I think that idea still matter. Right?
We're in this time where it seems like
they don't almost.
With all the social media.
Everything's fast phased.
You know, somethings happen and
you forget about it the next day.
And you [--].
But, I really believe that ideas can change
the world and their important.
And they have to be accessible.
That's the thing, you know.
I want to go into academia. But I also,
I wanna make my ideas accessible.
to journalism, you know,
whatever medium it can reach people.
And I guess some of my,
I think that the people I look up to,
for example, one of my heroes is
is Hannah Arendt. So, she was this
philosopher who is very famous
for covering the Eichmann trial.
And she basically went with her truth.
She settle lot of things that were not
easy to hear.
And she suffered a lot from that.
She kind of went with her truth.
And she had intellectual courage.
So, i think it's basically just thinking about
how we want to live us as a society.
And I want to do that through my research.
Through my writing.
Through politics.
So, do you see yourself as a contrarian?
as a goal?
I mean, are you looking for different areas
in which you can say,
"Okay. Well actually, something
is missing here. And I wanna do research
and I might prove that something
is different from what other people
believe or go against a crowd."
Or is it more general. Just research.
Yeah. I'm very interested in,
I guess the social contracts specifically.
How we live together as a society?
What's the glue that holds us together?
And as an Israeli, I'm interested in
you know, the Israeli context.
And I looked back to history,
to see kind of you know,
we were founded on the idea
about just society by these crazy teens
who came here and everything behind.
Not just to survive, right?
We talk a lot about existence in Israel.
Right? We have the holocaust.
We've gone through a lot.
But these young people also
thought about content of Jewish life
in Israel. They thought about what kind
of society they want us to live.
What is justice.
So I think we can gain inspiration
from that. So, I'm very interested in,
kind of a connection between history
and kind of politics and the future.
How we can build society better?
I wouldn't say I'm a contrarian.
I do think I have a critical mind.
I try to question a lot of what I hear.
Yeah. So, I guess I just like to understand
what's going on around me.
So, social contract.
I automatically I'm thinking about
society and the social contracts of today.
Versus you know,
when my parents grow up
or my grandparents who are
on the Kibbutz. So, you know today
Oh Kibbutz? Yeah.
I mean, I love our families.
We're on the Kibbutz right.
All of our American cousins,
live in the Kibbutz in somewhere and,
But it sounds like today's social contract
is very much guided by technology.
And by the different ways in which
we perceive social contracts
in communities. So, how do you
also become a part of that thinking
and that thought process as a historian?
Because you have to both understand
where technology is going and how
it's shaping psychologically
our communities while looking at
the actual communities.
Yeah. So, I guess I have two points
on that. So, for the first thing I wanna say
about social contract is,
I'm not sure what a social contract is
anymore. I heard someone say,
this professor called Cornel West,
talking about the protest going
right now, Black Lives Matter.
While watching he said,
"The failure of a social experiment."
he thought that the social contract
like there was a breakdown.
I think we need, there's a lot of room
for you know political theorist
and historians to think about
what holds us together?
What connects us?
It's not just the individual.
But about the point in technology,
I totally agree with you.
The historian that got me interested
in all of this is Yuval Harari.
Okay. I don’t know if you read his stuff.
Of course. He's an Israeli historian.
He wrote this book called Homo Deus.
About technology and he kind of showed
you don't have to know the
needy greedy of technology.
You need to have literacy, I think.
And that's something that I'm working on.
I'm not the best at it.
I'm working on it, but
you don't need to know the little things.
You can critique it as a human.
Like, that's part of the role of humanities.
We keep talking about the crisis
of the humanities.
It felt like part of our role is
to talk about ethics and to ask questions.
And you don't have to understand
how to codes to do that.
A 100%. And I can spend it
the other way around and say,
"Well, what worries me is that, I'm a part
of the group that is developing this
technologies and I consider myself
an innovator and that I hope
to one day I build something that will
influence society and perhaps change
the social contract.
And hopefully improve it for the better.
Yet, unless I study ethics and philosophy,
And unless I study history.
How can I hope to be able to make
a positive impact with my actions,
if I don't know what happened before?
So, what it feels to me,
which is a little bit worrying is that
we have two different populations going.
We have the technology population
that is really focused on the
artificial intelligence and prepping
these platforms.
And then you can have a clear
distinction to historians and
more humanities people who,
and there's not necessarily
a healthy communication.
Absolutely. Where is this going?
100% agree.
This has been a problem way back.
People have been thinking about this
for a long time. I think you actually see it
on, I mean we go to Stanford and
we see it on Stanford's campus
all the time. There is like,
I don't know if you know this,
but there's like the name of like,
the techies and the fuzzies.
The fuzzies are like,
I did not know that.
Yeah, it's kind like of old,
I'm not cool enough yet
to be in those clubs.
Well, I guess you're a techie.
So, you don't need to worry about it.
But, you know it's,
What's the fuzzies?
Fuzzies. Like they're not doing anything
really important. it's soft, you know.
Yeah, and there's just this disconnect.
There's you go to one part of the campus
which is the humanities.
And one part is, the engineering quad.
And you do all the cool stuff there.
And there's this feeling that that's where
the future is.
That's how you gonna change the world.
In technology.
But we need to bridge those things
in a meaningful way.
And not just talk about it.
And it's hard.
It's about rethinking our curriculum,
Yeah, and we haven't figured it out yet.
But it's definitely,
I love being a humanity student
on Stanford’s campus
because it's so techie.
I think about issues, you know
like artificial intelligence things like that.
Which I wouldn’t think about
if I was on the, I think east coast.
100%. So, Anat I mean, you don't
just study. You're writing articles for
a bunch of different well-known
publications and you really are starting
to become a proud leader.
And writing some pretty interesting stuff.
So, where do you see yourself going?
For I have the privilege on one hand
speaking to a lot of people in their
40s and 50s who've done a lot
and have already their world impact.
And now I get the chance to speak
to somebody ahead of me.
If I had to bet on anybody in the world,
I would probably bet on you.
That you're gonna do some crazy stuff
for humanity.
So what path do you see yourself now?
Going to Oxford. Rhodes scholar.
Where do you go from there?
Yeah. I mean my goal is to get my PhD.
In Oxford. Continuing history.
And then I see my future in Israel.
That's where my family is.
That's what I care about.
And I wanted to have one
kind of like rooted in Academia studying
the past but also, like kind of rooted in
writing and politics and teaching.
Thinking about the present and the future
And teaching the next generation
about, you know inspiring them.
And I think we need that. We need to,
Yeah. I mean I don't know what you
think about what is going on.
Israeli politics is madness right now.
It's crazy.
It was madness when you interviewed
Larry Diamond and Hillel back then.
And it's even more madness right now.
Yes it was. Yeah, we did a talk about
one of the Israeli elections.
One of the three or four.
I can't even count anymore.
You know you lose track.
Yeah. Well I see myself kind of
thorough thinking and scholarship
and writing. Hopefully, you know.
Thinking about the future.
And how we can design our society better
I love it. Are there specific questions
that you see yourself diving deep
into research? Or are you keeping at an
open mind and really understanding that
yeah, things might change a hundred
and may decrease by the time
that I'm ready to dive into them?
Yeah, at the moment I'm thinking of
continuing of my under-graduate thesis.
I'm really interested by this world of
socialist thoughts.
And I guess kind of European
intellectual history.
Just kind of this big ideas.
Like Marx and like Nicheli.
All these big ideas that really
permeated into different movements
around the world.
And you know what's crazy?
It's kind of inspiring for me because
going to high school in Israel.
We went through citizenship classes.
Yeah.
It was awful. I didn't know.
I mean looking back, I didn't know
that my country was founded by a
radical socialist. I didn't know that.
We learn about their names.
Kind of our around, all the street names.
David Ben-Gurion, [--]
Katznelson. These were leaders who
believed in universal values.
I'm not talking communist.
I'm talking more of a just society.
Like Kibbutz idea of living together.
So, we have to find inspiration in that.
And we have some of the coolest thinkers
in kind of labor scientism.
So that's what I'm thinking right now.
That's just fascinating.
Anat, what are you looking ahead now
at Oxford. What are you gonna actually
study there?
So, I'm gonna study Intellectual History.
I'm going I think continuing kind of on the
history of the Kibbutz.
The time the Kibbutz history,
not just to kind of Zionist
and Israelis studies but also to the world
of socialism and revolution.
And try to understand how the Kibbutz
fits into that.
And whether the Jewish experience
in Israel-Palestine,
I mean, it was Palestina before
So, how does that fit into
other kind of movements.
Fascinating. Well after this call I,
now I understand how much I don't know
about the origins of where I came from
and the Kibbutz and radical.
[--]
So, I'm gonna need you to send me
this honor's thesis which already won
all of the awards.
So that I can enjoy it myself.
Anat, before we go.
And it's just so fascinating.
Thank you for your time.
I'd love to know three words that
best describe you and I'm gonna ask you
the same question in about 20 years
after you've changed the world.
So, I'm gonna test you on how
consistent you are.
Okay. Well, I think the first one is Curious.
'Cause I really want to understand
what's going on around me.
I think then it's you know, a Thinker.
So, all the time I'm thinking.
And I think, Passionate.
Well, I'm really kind of
It's hard for me to do things
that I don't enjoy and so,
when I get into a project,
am just like, I'm consumed by it.
I love it. And you know Anat,
before we leave, I do have to mention
that I get to speak to quite a few
Stanford students and Harvard students,
and Princeton and students in Israel.
It is so rare to talk to somebody
who is so passionate about what
their studying in.
We do know these phenomena
especially in the Ivy Leagues in the US
that a lot of students are pressured into
studying a subject because it's prestigious
and it's what's their parents think
or what is society is saying in school.
A lot of the techies unfortunately.
I like that. And I'd love for you
maybe just give me a you know
one or two sentences about
you know, we're coming in from a
little bit more mature background.
We've done the military.
We've command and we've been a part
of teams and we saw some of the bigger
level of questions that the world is
dealing with. So, if there's any
undergraduates who are deciding
their major, or are thinking of what to do,
and they are hearing this.
What advice would you give them
after having gone through
this experience of following
your passion?
Yeah. I think that you're just gonna
do better if you do what you love.
Don't be afraid. The world is a mess
right now. We need humanities people.
We need people to think about
what's going on. The social contract
is being torn apart all over the world.
I think in America, you see
a very visually, the riots and the protests.
Totally.
But don't be afraid of just following
what you love.
I understand the pressures.
And I understand those things.
But, I would encourage it.
I think the simple thing is you know,
just be better.
That's the bottom line.
You'll love coming it to work, you know.
That's beautiful. That's beautiful.
Anat, toda raba.
Thank you for the time.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And best of luck with
Rhodes scholarship at Oxford.
And then hopefully PhD
and change the world.
We're gonna have to do some
pretty frequent check-ins over here.
Awesome.
Thank you so much for having me.
Take care.